it's a Monday PFT ot we do it on the
road as well we're still in New York
City capping what was a crazy show that
was largely devoted Andrew Luck and
Chris let's talk about one thing that we
touched on a little bit during the two
hours that we were on NBCSN
the criticism of Andrew Luck from the
booing by the fans who were at the
stadium and were reacting to what popped
up on their phones to guys like Doug
Gottlieb Avesta fs1 who then got slammed
by traitement a fox which Fox and fs1
are the same thing yeah Steve Beuerlein
former NFL quarterback who calls games
for CBS I believe he had some critical
comments isn't fair for people to to
throw these these negative takes in
Andrew Luck's direction I don't think
it's necessarily fair no I don't you
know I can understand I think the one
part that you brought up that I can
understand the most is maybe the fans
booing at the stadium because they love
the Colts and they want the Colts to be
gosh a lot of people are saying that we
could be a Super Bowl team this year and
they saw the way the team looked last
year and all the positives and just
everything seems like it's going in the
right direction they saw how great
Andrew Luck was last year so aspirations
were extremely high so I think from the
standpoint of the logo on the helmet and
I love the Indianapolis Colts I get that
but I think when you get into the
personal territory of Andrew Luck and
you start talking about a human being
who has beaten his body to crap
throughout his career and been very
selfless that way and I don't think has
told us about every little Nick you know
Nick and you know like a little bang and
bruise he's gotten throughout his career
I do not think it's fair you can't put
yourself in his shoes to know what it's
like to deal with his body on a daily
basis and the issues he's dealing with
and I think we got to be very careful
going down that territory I think it's
an intensely personal decision and I
don't want anybody playing football who
doesn't want to play no right that
that's the bottom line what whether it's
Chris Borland whether it's Andrew Luck
whether it's Vontae Davis who retired
during halftime of a game last year and
received a ton of criticism look if
you're not willing to continue to go out
there and expose yourself to the risks
inherent to the game then you should not
go out there and unless you are
completely and totally all
what a mike Mayock say last week about
Antonio Brown you got to be all right
you got to be all in and if you're not
all in then you have to be all out and I
don't say I look and one we don't know
that this has just happened right now
like we don't know we can all say oh how
could you quit on your team or whatever
else you know I mean from all we've seen
at this point it certainly seems like
they knew since before Monday okay
all the signs all the things that you
and I do we're obsessed with football
offspring and now if you put it all
together okay it looks like this is
something that's been known by the
organization at least to some extent
prior to this week I mean and he's not
just necessarily quitting on the team
out of nowhere I think the team has been
preparing to move on from him and maybe
that's why we've seen some of this
injury stuff and jacobi percent taking
all the reps because they've been
grooming him for something they thought
there was a good chance he might have to
take over and when we say that the I
mean the team there's so many different
departments and layers and levels like
if ownership knew in the front office
knew and the coaching staff knew there's
got to be somebody in that organization
who was shocked to find this out yeah
and then you have guys wondering why
wasn't I in the loop like how many
players actually knew about it how many
how many of the people who are connected
to the team and and maybe think they're
more important they really are were kept
in the dark mean it's just kind of a
weird dynamic that they're gonna have to
work through yeah because they opted
whenever Andrew Luck first came to them
to say hope don't do anything rash right
let's take some time it's I'm sure it's
hovered over the team for longer than
they're letting on and I think that that
there could be some fair criticism for
the way that everyone has handled this
Colts and Andrew Luck right but once
you're sure you don't want to play then
it's over then that's it and maybe what
the coach should have said to him from
the moment he first uttered anything
about it it's like look if you're not
gonna play we need to know now we don't
need to know in late August we need to
know now so we can make our decisions
almost like what the Packers did with
Brett Favre in 2008 right well I think
they were setting him up to retire right
as they knew if they said in February we
have to know right now then the answer
would be our retire and they barricaded
the door with furniture and hoped he
wouldn't come back but I almost feel
like from the Colts perspective in
hindsight the one thing they should have
done differently is the FIR
time they caught wind of it just say you
okay you're out we're moving fry well I
think that's easier said than done when
you have a Super Bowl ring and trophy
dangling in front of you where you feel
like this is a year we finally have a
team around Andrew Luck like you
mentioned to where we can do it I would
bet though yeah I mean you make up some
you you have some good questions there I
would bet no players knew until very
recently I would think this is an owner
Chris Ballard Frank Reich may be another
you know the quarterback coach may be a
few other guys on the staff in general
but I would think not too many people
within the organization would have known
about this conversation until until very
recently you're playing in that locker
room are you pissed off that they kept
it from you Tom no I'm not pissed off
I'm not I think with the players in the
locker room we're gonna be disappointed
because they're gonna they're thinking
the same things we were gosh to me we
really thought we had a chance this year
all we like Jacoby ever said they're
gonna turn the page very quickly but I
think they realize this is a very
important conversation and these are
things that players don't get the pervy
of knowing all the time the Saturday
night tweet from Doug Gottlieb of fs1
retiring because rehabbing is quote
unquote too hard is the most millennial
thing ever hashtag Andrew Luck it was 24
hours later where Troy Aikman jumped off
the top rope that's total bull bleep
Doug what qualifies you to decide how
someone should live their life so you're
now the authority on what motivates
Andrew Luck and if his decisions don't
fit into what you think is best for him
then you rip him guess that keeps you
employed on fs1
that's really the shot because Fox and
fs1 are the same thing and right now the
Troy Aikman's not a big fan of FN swans
hiring decisions because he doesn't like
to get Bay let's get Baylor said some
things about Eggman during his career
that Aikman took exception to and then
Fox went and hired Skip Bayless so
there's been that tension there and it
makes you wonder what Troy Aikman's
expiration date is at Fox yeah and he's
talked in the past that he's got
frontiers beyond TV and he's been doing
that gig forever but you know what Matt
maybe I looked at that the willingness
to go all-in on fs1 right I almost
looked at that as an indication that
Troy Aikman is at the give no F's stage
of his time with Fox where if they don't
like it fine you want to get rid of me
fine you want me off fine you're gonna
complain about it fun I don't care I'm
gonna say what I believe and I'm either
on your team or I'm not but if you want
me off
that's fine yeah well I don't think he's
scared either way I mean he's Troy
Aikman I think he's gonna land on his
feet regardless let alone I'm sure he
saved a boatload of money so this is not
gonna make him break him either way
hey I like Troy Troy is not afraid
awesome there's a number of there's been
a number of really instances through the
last few years in the NFL where he's
been very outspoken about certain issues
I like Doug Gottlieb too I don't agree
with him there at all I mean I really
don't again this is not a millennial
thing it wasn't like hashtag gets too
hard to rehab I think it's hashtag
everything's too hard mental physical
grind his body doesn't feel the right
way and again this is a guy who's done
nothing with just like Oh narcissism and
his career he shown us none of that it's
always been team and giving credit to
everybody else and telling a guy when he
gets knocked down by terrell suggs hey
good hit man good hit I mean he's all
overly giving in his praise other people
so I just you know he's not a bad guy
he's not selfish selfish and he's got
issues with his body and he's not
comfortable all right let's move on
Minnesota Vikings have a quarterback who
is all in the question is how good is he
Kirk Cousins had a subpar performance
against the Cardinals not exactly a
defensive juggernaut on Saturday and I
know
look third preseason game we put more
emphasis on it Cousins had looked good
the first game not as good the second
game should the Vikings be concerned
with cousins 3 of 13 performance well
it's not pretty I'm not gonna say
concerned and you know and again I don't
like care about the stats so much you
know that especially this time of the
year but I will say this just the
quality of some of the footballs he
threw up in that game I mean they were
ugly there's a few that really got away
from them where you saw like a wobble
and it was really off target I think
that's what maybe concerned me more than
anything but this is one of the big
questions about this football team in
general you know is what does this
offense gonna look like I think there's
some bright spots you saw Dobbin cook
your running back break an 85 yard run
that's great you saw the motion of the
offensive line going left he cut because
that one cut you Tommy back it was after
a Kubiak brings in I think you know
great leadership and knowledge the run
game should improve my big question with
the Minnesota Vikings is the past game
they have two options everybody else's a
little
I know Kyle Rudolph can be very good if
he stays healthy and everything like
that but it's been feeling and digs digs
and dealin for two years in a row that's
all there's been to it and gary kubiak
passing offense has not necessarily tore
the NFL up and of course Devin's Kevin
Stefanski is also improving that
unproven that way too so I'm interested
to see where it goes with this Viking
offense not not panicking yet but but
you're right with with Diggs and feel
and one of those guys gets injured I
want to jinx them but who steps who yeah
we don't know right there wait for
somebody to step up to be number three
step up to be number two in that
instance who knows at this point flip it
over to the Cardinals offense a lot of
questions about them after the game
against the Raiders they looked better
and it's been called the prettyboy
offense and Kyler Murray has seemed
frustrated by the way that the Raiders
came after him but it seems like we saw
a little bit more I agree we feel a
little bit better about the offense
after the week three preseason game in
Minnesota definitely I mean Kyler Murray
certainly looked better I mean they
certainly it seemed just at the very
base level and I haven't watched the
film yet Mike and you know I will it
seemed like they handled protection and
how to deal with blitzes and things like
that better
Kyle Murray certainly looked more
comfortable I think the biggest thing is
its preseason game number three as we've
talked about I really think the week
before they were caught off guard by a
team that game planned for them a little
bit more than they were ready to be game
playing for and this week I think there
was a few things in their offense where
they Unleashed him to get their offense
going in the right manner and it was
more the Kyle Emery I think you and I
saw in week one where we whoa Wow there
was more of a WOW factor II made some
phenomenal throws and honestly I'll tell
you I'm you know as much as we were
concerned about that Cardinals e that
Vikings defense letting up some of the
big plays they did in that game I think
was surprising to me as well all right
let's talk before we move on Carli Lloyd
the US soccer star who kicked the 55
yard field goal last week in a joint
raven CBS madness she tells Peter King
she thinks I know not I think I know I
could actually probably do it that's in
response to being a kicker in the NFL
put on the helmet strap on the pads go
for it the mindset I have I think with
practice I know I have to work on my
steps and my technique but I think I
could do it and do it
well do you agree I do agree I mean
again this is it's kicking okay I don't
think this is like oh you know if you
have a strong like you got a strong leg
I don't think anything else matters
there and I obviously she can do it now
hey she's gonna have to deal with you
know I mean certainly criticism guys
probably saying crazy things to her on
the football field but no they might not
say anything about yeah yeah fans yes I
think other football players should be
respected I won't cross the line into
like women territory or anything like
that I agree with you there there are
certainly gonna talk crap to her
regardless I think but I think she could
do it I would actually really love to
see her get an opportunity to go out
there and see if it can translate to an
NFL football field the one thing when
you watch the film of her kicking last
week and and and she will be able to
learn this with reps yeah you can't wait
for the ball to be played right before
you start toward exactly start you know
your targets not there yet yeah but in
soccer you do that all the time you'll
dissipate the arrival the ball you start
swinging your leg the ball swings over
and you hit it so I think she'd be fine
the leg is the key thing right the
ability to pull under pressure is the
best that they can teach exactly she's
shown that she can do that yes and
there's teams out there they don't know
what the hell we're gonna do a kicker
why not right why not give her a chance
I I hear you I'm the SMDs
made a good poem we talked about this
the other day the idea that you know
there could be a team out that it's out
of playoff contention and it would you I
mean your time that you're trying to yes
I'll take you trying to sell tickets
you're trying to something interesting I
see you little girls wearing corduroy
jerseys everywhere already right now let
alone Lord would do for the NFL right
and then maybe you all take some of this
stigma away of like oh the NFL so
dangerous and football so dangerous
which I'm really getting sick of arguing
as a father as well you know when again
the youth concussion rates in soccer
higher than the youth concussion rates
in football but nobody wants to talk
about that so that might help the sport
in general - all right Captain Planet I
can't help but anything about too far
that time the football has become the
sport that is the pin cushion everybody
does agree I know there are plenty of
other sports hockey soccer plenty of
other sports that's right head injuries
and you know I don't disagree with what
you said you just I just know it's like
clockwork and it I don't I got to bring
it back sometimes I'm living it
now it's probably gonna be my grievance
this week I'm just letting you know
right now because my little boy is
started to play football and I I'm just
I'm seeing it from every angle all
you're gonna let them play football
oh are you scared huh I mean it's just
constant it's it's this constant attack
by the media people everybody on the NFL
right now and I don't think everybody
has their facts straight all right we
got to go everybody have a great Monday
we'll do this again on Tuesday check us
out all day long at Pro Football Talk
calm and thanks as always for some of
your time
[Music]
you